HYFR risen TV i'm nick gillespie our
guests today are Jason tally and Pete
air of motorhome Diaries com a website
devoted to their interesting adventure
which is commencing in a few days guys
tell me uh what are you going to be up
to in a month's time or so well this
morning we just bought our RV Pete and I
split it half and half and we're getting
ready to a launch a website motorhome
Diaries calm where we're going to take
video blog and even tweet as we cross
the country talking to people who are
working hard to promote freedom and also
telling the stories of people that are
victimized by a government what's what's
the basic route you're going to be
taking or do you know is this a kind of
update of The Merry Pranksters
Adventures of further the bus what winds
will blow you away yeah initially we're
actually going to leave this friday or
saturday and we're going to head up to
New Hampshire and that's going to be our
home base up there there's a lot of
really good freedom or dead folks and
some activists and on the way we're
going to we're going to have two stops
we're going to talk with a guy in
Maryland who also just bought an RV and
who's also really into this freedom
movement and who plans to move to New
Hampshire and then we're going to meet
with some other people just outside of
Philly and have like a social and just
kind of get some folks on board and then
after that we plan we have to be out in
LA for the end of April so we're just
going to travel across the country what
what inspired this madcap adventure
obviously you're calling it the butter
site or the motorhome diary so there's a
reference thereto che guevara not quite
a freedom fighter but where did this
idea come from it's about time for me to
leave DC I got to get out of here I mean
Obama is coming in and the only growth
industry in America right now is
government and so we kind of want to
tell the stories about what's going on
and how his policies are affecting
people and of course the the the awful
policy is a george bush and tell a lot
of the human stories that that are going
on in America reaching out right yeah
it's not just those folks we just want
to talk about the institution of
government but for me you know being a
district remain studies and work
k office network program and then a
bureau crash you know really seeing the
strength of the networks and and when
you make personal connections with
people how they can it they can you know
builds that affinity and they can reach
out to people in their sphere so we just
really want to get out there and
personalizes so to borrow a phrase from
our president it's going to be like
community organizing and so you know we
want to meet up with a lot of
libertarians along the way kind of
network them all together and hopefully
keep them going and because I mean you
know we're under attack right now and so
this would be a good opportunity to get
people to organize what where are you
going to be posting your video it's a
well going to be our youtube account but
everything is going to go through butter
rum diaries calm ok and then can you
talk a little bit about free agents
dot-com what is that free agency com is
a website we talk about the news and
views from the front lines of freedom we
also are getting ready to start free
agents net which is going to be a social
network so as people hear about us and
as we meet with people we want them to
continue talking and collaborating with
one another I talked a little bit about
the new media component here both of you
guys have worked a bureaucrat you do new
media video things like that how how has
new media intrinsic to your operation
here it's crucial I mean we're going to
go out and interact with people and help
to tell their stories so for us we just
want to have a lot of cameras shoot a
lot of video and and right away you know
we'll be able to edit the video and get
it online and build that community what
is what's your dream outcome of this
trip will probably have a book if we
have good footage and we're gonna take
tons of footage so we'll have these
small videos but also put it together
for maybe a documentary and then when
that's done we can do a book tour do you
have you know what's up what's a story
that your itch in the towel do you have
any prototypes of the you know a
specific cases that you're talking about
well I mean even just this morning when
we were picking up the RV you know a
couple guys came by that worked for the
electrical company and they were
shutting doing some things at the
transformer nearby and they asked us
what we're doing and we told them we had
this you know 10 min interaction with
them and they were
you know pretty much in agreement I mean
obviously they're not they don't know
who Rothbard is and and that kind of
stuff but they basically said yeah you
know we earned our money we should be
able to keep it and I don't like these
politicians or bureaucrats they don't
know better than we do and just like
that kind of mindset for me it's we're
going to be getting out there you know
putting these people in touch with each
other building these communities and you
know I think half the battle is exposing
people these ideas so and then the other
half is making sure you have a full tank
of gas to get the hell out of town is
there can you point me to an RV story
that ends well I've been raced with the
devil it ends spoiler alert it ends with
demonic Satan worshipers Killing war
notes are in fondant okay you know lost
in America they barely make it out of LA
and end up in a trailer parking or and
Arizona like that movie we are gonna put
all of our money together and gamble it
that's that's that's our business plan
you know I saw your first stop is
actually foxwoods casino in Connecticut
when are you taking off friday saturday
okay and then you'll be in LA in April
that's correct yeah the Liberty forum
that alice is running and then you will
be what you'll be coming back as well or
do you drive it into the ocean we're not
gonna drive into the ocean hopefully
we'll turn turn back to where exactly we
haven't decided but yeah we'll be back
in DC in a couple months and wouldn't
hopefully we'll have some stories to
tell yeah well we'll look forward to
having you back and we'll be checking in
at the mobile home died or motorhome
Diaries calm for your updates and
Twitter and all of that those are crazy
new media tools yet I want to thank my
guests Jason tally and Pete air of
motorhome Diaries com we'll be checking
in with them over the course of their
trip for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie